hello everyone welcome to the session
my name is guilherme if your portuguese
accent is not that good feel free to
call me gee
i work at checkout if you want to know
what you do just go to the booth on the
exhibition area my colleagues will tell
you more about us
so
what i wanted to to talk about with you
today
is based on the perception that i have
that in this industry
we have really good patterns really good
architectures
really good concepts that we try to
apply in our day-to-day life
and they are they are perfectly fine and
we we love them the problem the problem
usually starts when you try to combine
multiple things
and that remember me the
when a theoretical physical
will try to reconcile quantum physics
with the classical
mechanics right so that comes to the
grand unified theory of clean
architecture
obviously this can be fake news i can
promise to and if i unify everyone but
at least i will give my best to do it
so
if like me you have been in this
industry for a long time
or at least you have chain jobs you
have on board multiple people
you have seen many many things in code
reviews and so on in new projects
and some of those things may have lead
you to questions like
what the hell is a unit test in this
company right
or for example where should i write this
test is is common as well when you have
such a long pyramid that no one
understands what they should do
or for example when you are reviewing a
code in an architecture where there's a
folder named domain
but no one seems to care and everyone
tries to to bring everything into
application services and so on
or the worst of all
and this one is really bad
oh
why i didn't invest in bitcoin early
because that way we'll solve all those
problems we wouldn't care about that
but unfortunately i'm on your vote as
well i'm not sure what is happening
okay maybe i can't approach my laptop um
okay so
what i want to bring you today is my
view on how to simplify not only your
life as a developer but for for your
team as well and you can do that by
delaying a lot of decisions that you try
to take
too soon
and and also to simplify the way that
you see tests in your architecture
okay
so
to do that i want to bring you on on the
journey on my personal journey
and as every single good story it starts
with once upon a time
and just because i don't want to say my
age let's say but once upon a time i
started as a as a software developer
as
vb.net developer in asp.net forms yeah
you maybe feel feel the pain of that and
i also work with a thing that most of
you never heard about it for sure that
is water's notes with a language that
was plotted scripts from ibm
so at the time no one teached me how to
do proper coding i was just fresh out of
college
and code behind was my thing
spaghetti code was the only way to work
and the best thing that i could do was
extract code into a comments folder
many of you have seen that code maybe
you have seen my call as well
so
one year later i decided to join
university because i was feeling that
there should be a better way to do
things
and so i i work nine to five every
single day and by the end of the day
during the night i would study
and in the university i was introduced
to a thing from 1992
that is the three-tiered architecture
that also led to the famous
multi-layered architecture so on one you
have the client server database
while on the other one you have the
that application layer business logic
layer presentation layer i i bet that
most of you have seen that in place
but no one told me about one thing that
is from 1992 as well that is the entity
control boundary by ivari jakobson
i don't know why no one told me about
that maybe would be useful
but reality is that i was really excited
with that multi-layered architecture i
could finally organize my code
i could stop doing all that spargapi and
start building a lot of lasagnas
so i went back to to the office and i
tried to apply that everywhere
i was becoming a good cook
but as anyone has cooked the lasagna
before
do you know where you start
by the bottom up right and if when you
get to the top layer and you understand
that you forgot an ingredient on the
bottom one
you are screwed it will take a lot of
mess to get there
and the same happens with software so
even having a better organization of my
source code
i was finding that often we come back to
that application layer to review things
because when you start with a
multi-layered architecture what the
first thing that you will do is
basically one is what is that the base
that i want to use basically that and
when you do that you always use the same
i can assure you
and then you go one step further and you
start trying to come up with the
database schema
right
then you move on you implement your data
application layer and then you move on
and you go to your business application
layer
and there are some people that say
the business logic player is the most
important thing of your application
right
i agree with them
but reality
many of you should know this better than
me is when you are writing code that you
discover most of the requirements of an
application
you can have the better product team in
the world they will do a lot of
investigation in the beginning
but you will find a lot of things as
well while you are implementing
especially the business logic layer
so when you find problems there you need
to go back to the database to review
sometimes if you start from the bottom
up
and i was seeing that happening so so
commonly
to a point that when we have for example
we detect that you pick the wrong data
type
we just write down that thing and we
expect to have another thing that we
discover and we do that in bulk
so
the feedback cycle of a single change
was quite high
and that didn't make a lot of sense in
the world where
we start to have people like kentback
talking about extreme programming
yeah being really fast agile all those
kind of things
even two years later kentpack gets
together with
another people like martin fowler
alistair cockburn and so many others and
they came up with agile manifesto
and all those things are just about
being
really fast discovering things
collaboration feedback cycles
and i was feeling that this
multi-layered architecture was not the
way to to achieve that
so it should be a better way
and tdd
trying to do tdd with multiple
multi-tiered architecture was something
that to me didn't work
maybe my fault
but
i could try to learn it at the time and
i couldn't and
recently i finally
get to manage it after i moved my
architecture to different practice
so all these feedback things
i was not able to get it
and that was causing me a lot of
frustration
and then comes 2003 and eric evans
publishes a book about ddd
how many talks do you have on this
conference about tdd
many right one thing from 2003
almost 20 years old
and one thing
that it comes to the realization with
this book is the importance of that
business logic layer that i was told you
so
my end goal is basically one is how can
i start developing my business logic
layer without
needing to come up with a database first
luckily in 2005
alistar cochburn was
having the same problem that i was
having he was working on a project
and two teams have different
responsibilities one of them
was responsible to build that
application layer let's say and the
other was responsible by the business
logic player
and they couldn't match in the schedule
where they could deliver the things in
the expected time because one need to go
first and the other one only could come
after so alistar come up with this idea
of
why don't we have a contract between us
and that led to
a really simple thing that is the
realization that all software as an
internal and an external side
okay on the internal you will put
everything that is really important for
you
everything that is special about your
application right and on the other
outside is everything else it's a
database is http is whatever is whatever
you want to pick but as you know
on that internal that in names as core
application you need to communicate with
the outside world
yeah there's no point of having code if
you can't execute it there's no point of
having code if it doesn't have effect on
the outside world
so it comes with this idea that
the core application should have ports
to communicate with the outside world
and to that those ports you can plug in
multiple adapters
and he goes one step further and he says
that there are driving adapters and
driven adapters i really love this thing
and i will explain why because
think about the following scenario and
i'm not sure if any of you is from uk or
another part of the globe where to pla
to charge your laptop you're in portugal
you need an adapter right
we came up with this idea of having
adaptations to things you don't need to
buy a new laptop
because you go to uk or you are from uk
and you come to portugal
why do you do that thing with software
so many times right it was basically
that realization but why having one side
that is the driving and the other that
is driven
because all of the all applications are
reacting to something are reacting to
web events
point and click
to on the console application and so on
and those are driving adapters
and on the other side they need to have
effect
on something like
updating something on the database
writing to the file system and those
will be your driven adapters okay so
this idea is really cool and there's one
extra thing that i really love that is
alister came up with an idea that is
every port should have at least two
adapters
okay
and why that is important because one of
the adapters that he says is the testing
adapter
so you you will come up with an
architecture that not only is device
independent
but also is really good for testing that
is what we are trying to achieve here
today
i try to do it and let's be honest i
finally like left the
lasagna behind and i come up with
perfect raviolis right
and my ravioli doesn't care of the
dressing it doesn't care of what sauce
i'm putting on the plate it's it's a
ravioli the meat inside is protected
from the outside
but even then i was finding that
my software was not that good so far
because we go after all those trends but
even then there's something missing and
you have feel that for sure
and
then it comes 2008
since i work
in the microsoft stack
i perfectly remember a time where every
single example by microsoft was based on
onion architecture
for those who don't know
onion architecture is basically
the way that i put it is ports and
adapters but with more more layers okay
because if you look into it he has the
same goals device independency but then
it's more more prescriptive what jeffree
palermo has done is that he will tell
you that you need a domain you need
repositories you need the main services
and when you don't have a lot of
experience
having all of that information is really
useful for you
so i i follow along but
yeah i keep working on that
maybe the problem is somewhere else
and then 2009
um
mike
on the book named succeeding with a
child it talks about the testing pyramid
and this was interesting because for
those that remember those those days
a continuous integration pipeline didn't
exist
your tests run once a day during the
night and you will be lucky if it even
starts
your changes will be tested with the
changes of everyone else in the company
and will go home and on the next day you
will realize that everything failed and
no one realizes why
so
if you have automation testing that was
what you will be doing because
most of tests at the time were done by
qa people okay but when we say qa people
we are not saying automation we are
saying we're going with the mouse click
here click here click here every single
day
is what they were used to do
the problem with that is when you have
one keyword person to eight developers
this doesn't scale right so you see
where the bottleneck will be
and what mike realizes is that most of
the companies like the ones that i work
for
only invest on
automating the part of the tests
where
you can remove that person from the
process
so you know the test scripts of that
person
let's try to
to automate those
you and what is this famous testing
pyramid that you have
heard about it for sure
it basically come up with this idea
your test portfolio should have
three layers okay you have unit tests
service tests ui tests
as far as you go up your tests start to
become really flaky they will take more
time to run they will take more more
time to write okay as far as you go up
on the other side you will have an
advantage one single test to an ui
component can test multiple things in in
your base right multiple components so
that's a good thing on the other side
but basically you he was advocating to
push
as many tests as you can down in the
pyramid
but there's a huge problem with this
thing that is
you know the discussion of what is a
unit test and now
if i ask everyone in in this room what's
your definition for a service test i
will get
maybe 20 different responses for for
this thing
and now imagine that you have an
application that is ingesting just
messages from a queue
do you have
ui tests
not sure
yes
that's a good one but many people
believe that you should only do it for
html or things that you can click with
selenium things like that
so if you go online and you start
searching for different alternatives for
this pyramid what we realize is that we
as software developers we think about
those things and realized that
mike was completely wrong he forgot a
lot of layers there and we need more
layers to solve those problems it was
not a problem with naming we just need
even more layers so now i don't know
when to write an api test or an
integration test
that was what is happening
maybe some people are right and we are
not that good with alien technology and
we don't
understand a lot about pyramids maybe
that's the reason
not sure
okay
2012 and
uncle bob robert c martin
publishes and think that he names clean
architecture at the time was a blog post
that then
led to a to a book
and on that blog post
it talks about
one thing that is this thing that is the
clean architecture that let me tell you
that this is not something new
okay
this is quite famous but it's nothing
new here
everything that is here you can get it
from ports and adapters from onion
architecture from ecb from 1992
what martin has done was combining all
those things in a single proposal
but this proposal has a huge flaw on it
and i will tell you about that in a
moment
but
there's a really good thing about this
thing
and then the other thing that you stick
the clean prefix
it will be a success you know clean code
can you imagine clean javascript
wouldn't be awesome or even clean
regular expressions i will finally be
able to do one
if you look into google trends you can
see this thing going up for clean
architecture while hexagonal and onion
are not that famous
so on the good side and why is important
to talk about clean architecture is that
many people are trying to follow along
with queen architecture
just because it's the most famous one
so
it's a good thing to talk about it
okay
now what i wanted to show you
is basically a demonstration of
why often we fail uh on this type of
architectures okay
why i tried so many times and i was
never happy with results
okay and i have a video for you
okay this is a perfect monolith let's
face it right everyone can agree with
that
and now we will see a junior developer
approaching the source code it tries to
refactor a single piece
and
you can you know what will happen
everything will follow apart
you may have a lot of questions now for
example why such a young person as a
developer is really difficult to hire
yeah we need juniors to start early
maybe
why this this developer is dressed like
elsa from frozen
that's a good question
it was the pandemic
you were working in pajama pants for
sure so why
she couldn't work in as a princess and
last question is she available for
hiring the answer is no unless you work
for disney okay
okay by the way she's my daughter
beatrice a round of applause for her
yeah everyone in the other room should
be thinking oh
hey thank god i didn't went to that room
we finished so early
um yeah okay let's let's continue
so this is what happens when you try to
to change one architecture
but you touch a single piece for a
simple refactor and everything goes
right you see all your tests going red
or the worst part is when nothing goes
red and or you even don't have tests
right
but that happens too often
and that happens because we forgot one
part of it that is testing
okay
so what do i do i discover
that we can do to reconcile those two to
unify them and let's start by the
architecture
i was telling you that there's a major
flaw on this proposal by robert c martin
right
if you look it in the colors you will
see
all the layers have different colors
this has the same same shape as onion
architecture from jeffrey palermo
but if you look into the jeffree palermo
approach you will see that he only uses
two colors and he has more layers than
this
he uses two colors and most of the
layers have a label that says
application car
okay
if you go online to see if i'm saying
the right thing just do one thing go to
exactly the blog where jeffrey has
published this thing because there are
so many people drawing that onion
architecture thing that you will find
this mistake on all those architectures
as well
for example
this is a common template that we see
online for clean architecture where we
we are smart people so we if the author
says that it should be use cases we name
it application
if the author says it should be here and
it is we name it domain doesn't matter
to be honest
but
usually we'll see something like this
where
you have for example an api or a web
application and on that infrastructure
you stick together everything that
connects to databases and so on
if you look into this
i can see only two things to be honest
i can draw a box there
that is my internal car that is the
missing thing from the previous diagram
and when i
divide this into things
i can map this thing to a portion
adapter diagram
okay
all that domain and application thing
can go inside of core application
and all the green things are my
infrastructure so they are adapters
but i can also say i can bring to onion
architecture that rule of one port two
adapters
okay as you can see there
once you come up with this
things start to become really simple in
terms of testing and i will show you how
so
my diagram of onion architecture
is a different approach
the way that i see it is basically this
you have one important thing that is
your core you can split it in
application
and domain
often i see a lot of domain projects
that are completely dynamic and you
don't reuse it anywhere but you have a
project just because okay just because
you are following along
and
around it you can find adapters
the the third layer for clean
architecture
the name is interface adapters is the
same concept of adapters at hexagonal
architecture
and i split those into i like the idea
of having driving adapters
for example web applications apis
message handling things like that
but also tests
those are important
the difference between these adapters
and the other ones that i will talk
about is that these ones
know the car application okay they can
trigger things in the car application
on the other side you have driven
adapters and those adapters
i can't move myself i need to go there
okay so
on the other side you have
databases file systems and so on but you
can also have tests there okay you can
mock things there as as you want you
just respect that
contract that you have with your core
once you get to this
you may think okay how do i organize my
things this is a possible approach how i
sometimes do it to be honest this
doesn't matter okay it doesn't matter if
you package your application as per
service per layer everything in one
single thing organized in source folders
doesn't matter okay
that doesn't matter at all if you are
building a microservice
and you have 10 projects
maybe you are doing something wrong
the important thing is respecting the
dependency rule
okay is respecting those layers pointing
inwards
right
and even more nuts even more but also
really important is following one of the
principles for clean architecture that
is a screaming architecture what is a
screaming architecture
is basically an architecture that you
look into
the folder structure and you can
recognize what this application does
instead of having names like controller
services repositories and everything
sticks together on the same page you can
do things like this for example have an
import something add something remove
something and you will target that
functionality it's a kind of feature
driven approach
by doing this you start organizing your
code better you can you can do better
refactorings for example you will not
bring a lot of responsibilities to a
single class
right
so
the most important thing that you can do
besides following along with uh with a
template that has three projects and you
think that is done
is thinking about the dependency rule
pointing inwards
and then naming things like like this
oriented to your approach to to the
feature
but
all of this will lead you to a point
where you have a different version of
clean architecture i didn't bring
anything really new at this part
but all of that as a reason and the
reason
is that
your
your application if you don't think
about how to test it
will fail
in my opinion you are not a good
architect
if you don't think how your application
will be tested
if you don't think about the cognitive
laws of writing a test
if you don't think about the friction of
writing tests and maintaining it
so if you look into your application and
you think that your tests are just a
different host
for your application it's like you are
deploying two things one for testing to
gaining confidence
and another one
to
to execute your application
now i need to drink water and i don't
know if i can approach my laptop
okay so
i will keep alien technology
i believe that if aliens came here to
build pyramids
for sure they are more
they are on a different point of
civilization when compared to us
and maybe the pyramid was a message for
developers one day they will come
and they will use this for as a testing
pyramid
but the difference is that i will say
that
developer tests
the pyramid is targeting developer tests
instead of all tests of your
organization
why
if you work in a company that works with
multiple services microservices whatever
there are multiple ways to approach
those things
and you will find that often you have
for example end-to-end tests going
through all the applications of of your
company for example
so i believe that the pyramid should be
targeting the experience of a developer
working on a single component
and i will name things differently i
will name it unit integration and
application and i will explain why in a
moment i keep the same variables okay as
far as they go up
will happen this the same thing
let's start by the unit this one is the
most problematic one
because everyone knows that there are 10
000 different
meanings for unit tests
the one that i like to use is the one
from michael feathers that doesn't
explain you what is a unit test but what
is not
okay and what michael will tell you is
that the unit test
can touch a database can't go through
the network doing something can't touch
the file system
can't go to the environment whatever
okay
so
a micros
a unit test should be something that you
can run as a kind of a pure thing okay
there's no influence from the outside
and if you look into our application
that looks like the kind of code that
you'll put on your core
right
because your core should be device
independent you shouldn't depend on
things from the other other sides
so if you unit test this core
you can also use your ports that i told
you
to write for example mocks
or fakes whatever that you want
right so by doing this
you have a better way to approach in
your your unit tests but even then you
can build a really messy thing okay for
example you can build something like
this
can you read it on the uh
yeah
i was expecting that you didn't have to
suffer like that
but
tests like this where eighty percent of
the code is mocking
this is a huge problem
this is the kind of tests that when
someone touches a single piece and
everything goes red
it's because of this okay
if you see one of those
this is a warning flag
this is one of the biggest problems with
many tests that you see out there
right
but what we can do
i always recommend to take a look into
the test diverata i'm not sure if i say
this right
this is that i think it should be
italian i'm not sure
that is a document by
kent beck and kelly sutton there's a
also youtube series that you can look on
on it where they describe a set of
principles for good testing
there are a few ones that i really like
for example
structure insensitive
do you think that all of those marks are
structure structure insensitive when i'm
trying to understand what they are doing
right
they say that should be behavioral
they should not be looking for is these
components invoked or not and they
should
be composable is also important there
are many more that you can take look
after
and often this happens because the way
that i see most developers approaching
testing is in a
solitary testing way okay
when you write solitary testing by the
way there's an awesome blog post by
martin fowler about solitary testing and
sociable tests that you can look online
basically solitary testing is when you
you are testing your system under test
that is that purple box
and you mock everything that you will
use everything
okay you will make sure that no matters
outside of that class or that function
will be invoked you mock everything and
then you came up with that thing that i
showed
so every time that you touch that code
you need to refactor your tests every
time that because of a refactoring you
need to touch your tests you shouldn't
trust your tests
yeah it's hard to listen that but you
shouldn't
what's the alternative sees sociable
tests right it's more collaboration
and you can build sociable tests if you
look into your dependencies and you just
question
according to michael federer's
definition of what a unit test is
if i use the real dependency here will
this be a unit test or not
okay so if you look into this one you
can think that for example this one is
maybe a database it's maybe a file
system it may be an api
but those ones
maybe are just mappers why i'm mocking
them
why do i want to write through extra
tests just because of that
yeah give it a try you will see how
different it feels once you start doing
this
and once you start doing this you will
realize that you often use those exports
or public access modifiers
just because of testing
right for example a mapper
from an
outside layer like an api to your core
application
why should it be public
it mapping is mapping to things from the
inside of that car i don't need it to be
public are you expecting someone to swap
out that mapper one day
i don't think so
once you start thinking that way you
will just focus on testing public things
when you just focus on testing public
things you will also have less things
public
because you want to reduce your contract
as much as you can
why let me tell you a story
in the past i developed an application
that generated a ton of code that
other our clients could use that code
for different different purpose
and we have there
as a folder saying something like
internal
with a lot of ugly code there
but we forgot to set some things to
private
okay one day on the refactoring
a developer thought we don't need this
thing to be public
let's change it no one should be using
this this isn't even documented
what happened
from all of our clients one
called complaining we are broking
something on their system
but they are right
we obviously we are developers and we
say oh you shouldn't be doing that
go say that to one of your most
important clients
yeah but they were right that thing was
public
and
do you know the hiram's law
the eram's law tells you that every
single behavior that can be observed by
the outside of your system
is a contract
think about that every time that you
expose a property every time that you
expose a method every time that you
expose anything
someone may be looking to that thing
they may even infer a given thing just
because you you are working in a given
way
so once you start thinking about this
what will happen is that you reduce the
number of tests that you do
you will reduce the number of things
that you are concerned
so you will have less friction on
maintaining your your tests
okay enough of unit tests let's talk
about integration tests
the way that i see integration tests
in the context of an architecture that
is device independent
is that instead of you testing
integration tests like i usually see
like
you have a tester
oh i have an api let me call the api the
api will use the application core the
application core will use the database i
test this all this thing integrated
perfect right
or for example
i have that web application that is html
i don't like selenium so i will just do
a kind of subcutaneous test that is when
you test one layer below
of that thing
you can do it that way as well
the way that i recommend you to do is
do you remember that i told you that you
have a contract between your car and the
outside world that is a port
right
why don't you mock your core application
you have a contract to fulfill
is the thing that you have to test
right
you want to test your database
you test your database adapter against
the real database
anyone have test things for example they
use a sql server or a my sequel and they
test against um a sequel light
no one use sql light for testing in the
past
i'm the only one okay two two friends
thank you um
when you do those kind of things you are
just that i think that you
you are not really testing the thing for
example i use that technique for a long
time
until the moment that i was using
postgres and using a particular function
from postgres that didn't exist on sql
lite
so what do you do
nowadays it's really inexpensive to spin
up a container a docker container
running your real database and you
quickly run your tests you are happy you
are done
right so what i recommend you to do is
you spin up your your container like
postgres
you look into your adapter is this
adapter doing what is expected to do
according to contracts yes perfect i'm
happy with it
that way every time that you go across
your api card and database and the test
file you don't know if the problem is in
the adapter on in the core itself
another example do you see those ones on
the left like an api
sometimes you may be testing for example
if a customer doesn't exist
and you call the api with a given id
that doesn't exist you return the 404
let's say right
why don't you mock your core application
and you say
i want you to return a null or or a mona
because we have mark simon here thanks
mark
and we you want to return them or not
saying okay this is an optional value if
it doesn't exist i will say it doesn't
exist
so why don't you mock that way and you
just test if you call your controller it
returns what you are expecting you don't
need all that word on of going back and
forth
right
so but maybe some of you are thinking
yeah but that way i'm not checking if
the adapter works with my application
and that is true
that is why i say that you should have
application tests
but there's a good news on that
you maybe already have it
because most systems already have any
kind of
end-to-end test functional tests
acceptance tests you name it is
something that tests real application
with the dependencies
in place and make sure that everything
boots up
for example since i've learned tdd
sometimes i feel too confident and i
don't even start the debugger
i'm that kind of person
so i write my unit tests i'm happy with
it and i send it to qa
what happens
someone that will test it on qa check
that i didn't inject the dependency
sometimes those things happen right if
you have your application test that is
some kind of thing that
runs everything and just do a kind of a
smoke test that everything is wireless
correctly
you will avoid those things
but
what i described to you was a way to
look into that pyramid in a different
way more prescriptive i would say trying
to unify with domain-centric
architectures
but what i didn't
told you about
is
is that that is not enough
i can give you a good example
uh i have here my friend sergio for
example and sergio
let's imagine that he brought a new car
and he subscribed the good uh insurance
for his car
okay
today he received the proposal of a new
insurance plan that has extra coverage
okay
something because of wildfires let's say
and the price is even slower it's
smaller
what searchers should do should we
subscribe the new insurance plan and
cancel
the the other one or should we keep both
option a right
shouldn't cancel the other one otherwise
you'll be paying twice
so why the hell do we keep
that multiple tests testing the same
thing
what i see so many times is that you
have a feature to accomplish and instead
of looking into the test that you have
and seeing oh this test should be
updated there is an extra assert that
you should be doing there for example or
let me test this thing
but only assert this new thing what we
do is that we copy the original test and
we add an extra line
isn't that brilliant
because it feels so so strange to delete
a thing that is supposed to be good
we are always proud to say we have
10 000 tests
yeah
that's not a motive to be
to be proud you should reduce your test
as much as you can
yeah that is the sun cost fallacies when
you feel that your investment on
something
can't be lost
and you feel that thing is good so you
don't want to remove it
so always look into tests in a way that
you can maintain them another thing that
you can do is always try to optimize and
duplicate
the end goal of a pyramid
is basically you
you want to make it efficient
okay you want to have confidence but
needs to be efficient
so for example every time that you spot
a test going red on your application
test the upper layer end-to-end test
acceptance test whatever you name it
look into the other tests and see if
something is red as well
if it's not it's a good opportunity for
improvement okay maybe
that asserts is something that is
missing on other place and on that case
just push it down see it's going red fix
the bug
or whatever sometimes you may not be
able to do it because it's in fact
an uh a problem with wiring up of
everything but those cases are really
rare
okay
so
went through we went through all this
thing
and
i really believe that this is helpful
because
anyone here remembers the
the flash ban by apple
if you don't even remember what flash is
the best way to describe it is like
if your website has a lot of tik tok
videos
built by a eight years old graphic
designer okay a lot of flashy things a
lot of colors
and you want to close everything
at the time in 2010
most of sites have some kind of flash
there or they were all built with flash
and flash was really a pain because
everyone struggle with it you need to
reinstall it multiple times your
windows and mark will fail because of
that so
one person i don't know if you know his
name is steve jobs
at the time no one give him a lot of
value by that but in fact they have done
a good thing for the industry
the problem is that a lot of companies
that were invested on another good
technologies that follow the same model
of having a plug-in in your browser
suffered with it as well
a lot of companies were following the
lead by microsoft on silverlight
and all the investment was lost
many of them just
stopped building that product because
they need to go back to the beginning
yeah
and what i believe is that if that the
time those companies have
an architecture
where
silverlight for example is just a
plug-in to their car
and they have proper testing on their
car application they will move really
fast to html5
okay
and what you don't want is that once we
have another
flash pen
the new thing
you don't want to be on that place i
assure you
so what i expect is that i have gave you
a simple way to look into your
architecture but without forgetting that
that thing needs to really be really
good to testing the cognitive load
required to writing a test should be
really small
your developers shouldn't even ask you
where they should write that test
okay
it's it's two paragraphs on the on a
wiki page saying this is this kind of
test this is this kind of test this is
this kind of test okay should be no
different
things that are difficult to decide and
to do that it's quite simple you just
start by your core application
okay you focus on your really important
things
you delay decisions to the future
okay you may think that is a good idea
to have a dynamodb database a postgres a
cosmos db whatever
but
don't start doing it until you are sure
of what you want on your application
card okay
when i say start by application code
obviously i don't say write all of your
application code and then move on to the
next phase
start do it in small cycles
but start with your application code and
write unit tests around them don't
forget to follow those rules
write tests in public
write sociable tests write tests that
are easy to maintain write less tests
let's say
then you implement your adapters okay i
want to use an api let me write an
adapter for that i want to use a console
application let me write an adapter for
that i want to write sql database write
an adapter for that and test those in
isolation as an integration test
and then you will combine everything
everyone will be happy and you you start
the the application to make sure that
everything is is okay
this is the most important slide that i
have on all this presentation okay i'm
proud of it
then if you print it and you send me i
can't sign it okay no problem with that
um
okay so
test
this is the strategy that i recommend
the good thing about this is that you
can apply this to any kind of uh
domain-centric architecture it doesn't
matter if it is clean architecture ports
and adapters onion you name it you have
the dependency rule pointing inwards you
can do this
okay it's that simple
and this has a huge impact you will see
it
okay i hope that i gave you a framework
to simplify
and i hope that you liked it okay thank
you all
we have a few minutes for
questions if anyone has
any question yeah sure
yeah so the question is basically for
example in the main driven design way
where you have an aggregate that
aggregate as entities inside
how should we approach that am i right
right okay so on on my opinion when you
go let's go back on the slides
good to do
here
that aggregate will be inside of this
thing okay
once this person by the way what's your
name
i don't know how to say your name
for sure you don't know how to say mine
as well
okay so
when he tries to to build something like
that i can assure you that he has a
strong domain model he was thinking
already about decomposing in aggregates
the entities and so on
the way that i see that you should do it
is through your aggregate that is the
most important unit of logic of that
system
doesn't mean that if your entity is
exposed to the outside and the outside
world can use it you shouldn't test it
you should because
every time that something leaks it's
public to the outside of one of those
concentric layers
you can you need to think that it
doesn't matter if it's a service from
your team
doesn't matter
anyone one day may depend on that thing
and on that case i want to be sure that
that thing is good so if you have
logic inside of that entity i will test
it as well
okay i don't know if i answer your
question
yeah kind of we can chat after maybe in
the concrete example any other question
no on that case thank you all for coming
okay and see you around
you